like forever ago you know a decade ago
my name is Ian Glen and I play said
Jorah moment he's an exiled night he'd
been banished because he was foolish
enough to sell slaves and Ned Stark
didn't like it he's trying to win favor
back in Westeros by keeping an eye on
the TUC Aryans and Dany in particular
the first time we see him he's at a
wedding of Khal Drogo and Daenerys judge
or anak Jorah arrives with this rather
sweet present songs and histories from
the Seven Kingdoms are you from my
country sir Jorah Mormont of Bear Island
his first movement is a dishonest buck
which we don't know at the time I served
your father for many years God be good I
hope to always serve the rightful king
he senses a sweet truth about Daenerys
throughout that first season he learns
to respect her but it's kind of what
what makes his love grow for her as well
seeing her cope with these difficult
circumstances and not just survive but
shine he witnessed her marriage to Khal
Drogo the death of her brother and seen
her cope with the death of her child and
then it all leads up to this funeral par
with Khal Drogo having died and it was
Daenerys entering the ashes of the pyre
and then she gives birth to the dragon
out of these ashes in that moment
everything comes together and he sees
this woman who's more than anything that
he could have ever imagined lot of my
plot I think we understand by the end of
season 1 that he is going to live for
her she's in a good mood and of course
Daario naharis is just careless and cool
overall which is really [ __ ]
irritating you know when all you've done
is really love this person tried to be
proper and property right and there's
dude comes in you know when this friggin
spinny [ __ ] blade and she gets all
[ __ ] that attracted to him I should
come here hmm
the dragon queen Daenerys Stormborn
heard me Jorah is at his worst
he's ruined by the greyscale and has
been kept in isolation unit and he's
just waiting his death and Samwell Tarly
pops up I knew your father I was with
him when he died
you're not dying today sir Jorah he
tries to take on the difficult task of
peeling off him against the odds
Sam saves jours life I returned to your
service my queen if you'll have me it
would be my honor he does notice Jon
Snow and I don't think he's as
threatened because he wants what's good
for her and that is feels like a good
alliance firstly thinks the army of the
Dead is nothing but a story made up by
wet nurses to frighten children what if
we proved her wrong tyrion comes up with
this plan to capture a white and that's
you know III think Jorah has any purpose
hanging about near Danny that's his he's
a fighter that's what he does he's got
the chance to fight for her again he
doesn't think twice about it
they go on this mad journey to try and
capture a white it all goes pear-shaped
and they look like they're all gonna
meet their maker when Danny flies in
and they all fly out but he sees her
lose one of her children
the dragon pit is a gathering of all the
various heads of departments trying to
work out what the best move is from here
there is only one war that muttered the
Great War and it is here the ground
except you choose until the dead are
defeated they are the true enemy and the
resolve is that they're going to face
the great war which is up ahead and
you'll all be right in the mix
everybody is Charlie we got a brand-new
Game of Thrones Season eight promo to
break down this time about Jorah Mormont
and Daenerys Targaryen storyline really
led the funny moment where Ian Glen
talks about Daario and Daenerys but
there's a lot of good foreshadowing for
his storyline during season eight so
we'll break it down there's a new round
of that Game of Thrones book giveaway -
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video to think about his backstories
they haven't really gone into that
recently but because they're coming back
to Winterfell
in the first episode in the first couple
of scenes he's going to be reunited with
a little bear eventually so they'll have
to address it in some way like the last
time that you were here Ned Stark could
have beheaded you for slaving your own
people but instead exiled you to Essos
and now you've come back so it's not
like that's suddenly water under the
bridge for the little bear and the
people of Bear Island and if you guys
weren't sure what his relationship to
little bear is the little bear is the
daughter of mage Mormon mage Mormon is
Joris aunt so the little bear is jours
cousin not his daughter or anything like
that he was married to Lynette Hightower
that was the woman who wanted really
rich wonderful fine things that he
needed money for so that's why he
started slaving so hopefully that
clarifies how the little bear is related
to surge Ora but the whole idea with the
little bear is that she's probably one
of the safest characters of all she'll
live on to continue to rule Bear Island
so just because Sir Jorah has come back
to the round with Daenerys and he's
seemingly redeemed himself he seems like
a good person he's been through the fire
metaphorically and psychologically
because of the trial with the greyscale
Samwell helping him get rid of it and
then just redeeming himself through his
actions in trying to serve Daenerys that
doesn't suddenly mean that everyone on
Bear Island is going to welcome him back
and tell him to take over and continue
to rule again there's a couple key
things that Ian Glen talks about when
he's talking about surge or a storyline
that gives you an idea for what he's
going to be doing during season eight it
all this foreshadowing about how his
story is supposed to end he has one goal
going into season eight and that is to
serve and die for Daenerys that has
always wanted to do since the end of
season one when he turned as he says
during this video when she stepped out
of the fire with the Dragons like he's
completely convinced that she is the one
remember way back during season
though when his treachery is outed
because of the royal pardon that arrives
in Barristan Selmy sees what does this
takes it to dinner since she kicks him
out big callback to the Lannisters if
you don't remember it's actually Tywin
Lannister that was behind that royal
pardon but it was varus's little birds
that literally brought the letter to
Barristan Selmy z-- hand Tywin was the
one that was behind the plot ultimately
because he wanted to neutralise Daenerys
'as quote unquote small Council he knew
Jorah Mormont was helping her out so he
wanted to take that away from her he
also knew about Barristan Selmy so he
wanted to try and isolate her as much as
possible it was successful for a little
while but it was just another trial that
those characters had to go through that
catalyzed them and brought them all back
together eventually he talks about his
relationship with Tyrion their amicable
I wouldn't call them best friends or
anything like that but they do have a
mutual respect for each other
they're also apparently based on Peter
Dinklage's comments now friends own bros
if you believe his comments about loving
Daenerys I think the difference between
Tyrion and Jorah is that Tyrion still
values his own life more than Jorah
values his own life an Tyrion also still
loves his family the Lannisters one of
whom Cersei is still currently one of
their greatest enemies in the great war
so jurors loyalties aren't torn in any
way like he's completely loyal to
Daenerys and wants to fight for her but
in doing that he's also helping serve
the north because now they have a common
cause the knight king in the army of the
dead is slowly marching down to
Winterfell
so just remember all those important
foreshadowing moments during season 7
like where England talks about Jorah
thinking that he doesn't belong in the
map table room planning battles he
belongs in battle which is why he is one
of the first people to sign up for Jon
Snow's mission to go beyond the wall to
get the white and bring it back to
Cersei he also has probably one of the
coolest season 8 foreshadowing scenes in
all of season 7 when they're on that
mission when he's talking to Jon Snow
about Longclaw so Jon tries to give it
back to him your father gave this to me
it served me well and he says no no no
keep it it belongs to you now
may this protect you and your children
which obviously is a big reference to
all the foreshadowing that they've done
since season one the Daenerys will
eventually get pregnant and have more
children with as you can see now when
Jon Snow Aegon Targaryen shall Hatchin
Dragon season seven episode six in
Episode seven had scenes that were
particularly on the knows about this
Daenerys goes on and on about how all
the Targaryens are dead except for her
she's the last one and there's
absolutely no way no way in a million
years that she would ever have more
children so big twist
of course she's probably going to have
another child with Jon Snow here also
more foreshadowing tying the Longclaw
moment back to Jorah and what's
happening with bear island now that he's
back in the north think about it this
way Jorah Mormont has technically been
pardoned by the throne so he's back in
the north meaning by rules of succession
Bear Island passes back to him instead
of the little bear based on the way he
treated Longclaw when Jon Snow tried to
give it back to him which was his by
rights in how he refused to take it back
also probably gonna be a similar moment
during season eight about the lordship
of Bear Island like regardless of what
you think is gonna happen to him he's
probably not gonna go back to Bear
Island to become the lord again surge
auras role in all this regardless of
whether or not he lives to find out
Daenerys is going to get pregnant again
is to protect her in fight and possibly
die for her so he's going to throw
himself on any White Walkers ice javelin
he can to prevent her from being taken
down like Viserion charging the field as
england says in the thick of it all like
he seems really excited to fight in this
big battle so even though the show
doesn't trade on happy endings for
characters it does feel like if you pay
off Joris ark you let him fulfill his
purpose which is to live and die for
Daenerys and see her be happy so even
though he's pretty high in my death
predictions list I still think that he
survives to see that Daenerys is happy
with Jon Snow that she's pregnant with
his child and she's relatively safe then
the show will probably allow him to die
so that would mean that he would
probably survive at least till the later
episodes but post all your early sir
Jorah season 8 predictions in the
comments below and for all of you asking
about that Game of Thrones season 8
trailer I do believe that they're gonna
drop that sometime before the end of
February so any time in the next two to
three weeks so just keep your eyes
peeled whatever ends up coming I will
totally make a video for it but leave
your requests in the comments below if
there's specific bonus videos you want
me to do
congratulations Jolie s you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Game of
Thrones video please email
on the about page of my channel so I can
get your contact details to answer your
question that's Podrick standing behind
Arya in his red armor and the courtyard
at Winterfell you can pick him out
because he's been wearing the same armor
this whole time click here for that new
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1
preview breakdown and click here for all
my other Game of Thrones season 8
trailer videos and promos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you